O
jeu de
n'a pas dit bientôt
ET là
je
je ne ferai rien
pas faux
ET là
[Musique]
Et puis il y avait beaucoup de l'existence de la
hommes dans la violence domestique contre les femmes
femmes et filles l'enfant alors
marcher les années dans le conseil à
expérience et prise de conscience dans
familles comme celle-ci, la violence a déjà diminué et
à dire et la moitié de progressiste ni nous
cas ici alors que dans les premières années
nous traitons de très nombreux cas de
violence mais maintenant c'est super pour le mois
une fois
[Musique]
ET là
je vais rêver
[Musique]
ET là
et tout cela à cause du système
que nous devons dans cette province est le
L'Afrique le système patriarcal tant
des fois où notre éducation a été dit que
cette femme n'a pas de voix cette femme
un temps de pouvoir décisionnel et
ET là
[Musique]